[noise]
"this is Monica Diaz and I am"
"? for Visible Lives an oral history of the disability experience at
of the New York Public Library. Today is Saturday, March 28
2015 and we're at the Andrew Heiskell Library in
Manhattan. And Alem, could, could you start off by telling us
a little bit about your background and yourself? Well, my name is Alem
Well, my name is Alem Blount. I was born in Brooklyn, New York. In the
fall of September %um but mostly raised
in Arizona and (...?)
I went to school in Brooklyn
(....) Milwaukee, Wisconsin.
Where I went to (...) school
Elementary School in Milwaukee, Wisconsin, where I learned how to play
the piano. But now I don't play anymore because
I don't know. I'm gonna get back to it
The reason why I was learning
piano was because it was music therapy for me
and I love playing the piano. It's good
relaxation and it's good
meditation, and it's good for me to
learn how to play because it takes away all the
stress and, and
Then I went to [inaudible] Middle School
in Milwaukee,Winconsin, and there
I was in Special Olympics
running track and field, and I love
I like to run and, I ran various
I won various awards and you know went
different trips out of state to run for Special Olympics
But then I graduated from [inaudible] Middle School and went to high
school at James Madison [inaudible] high school in
Milwaukee, Wisconsin. There I was in a group
called Sister to Sister, and I was an advanced
in my school, it was called the drill team, and I had
an excellent time
school, in high school because
at the end of my school year, I made a lot of friends
..and I was a popular girl, but I
was...nice to people.
I met a lot of people and, you know
I mean around in high school. I think I miss high school
more now than being not in college
you know, um, and, um
[inaudible] when I was a girl, um, sorry
[inaudible] when I was a girl, you know
to church, I went to
temple and from there, from Washington Temple
I was in the Girl Scouts in my church and I love being in
the, l- loved being in the Girl Scouts in my church
And while I was in school, I was in Girl Scouts as
well. [Inaudible] and I loved being in the Girl Scouts.
for me.
As a young
[silence]
[inaudible]
and years later do
not implement
broken in hours and hours and then I was I
was and the program will not assist and
from there I did a classical work. I shall now clerical work
. Couric And you know
stamping Colerain filing papers and
have them. I don't I would better put order
and I just love the FACAL work
to me
because thanks to the south side of the stress away.
And it may show more focus more
work then so it's going
around in your mind
and you know and I will restore our own climate
program in not getting
any money. I let him pay money and
my human human
resources to help
in a lot of employers
. Well they weren't acting Colerain filing
faxing. So I learned how to do so that will
work and other for now
. Patterns are changing the way you need to learn more
about good throughout who work and how to do at so
do and I want to do that so you
know what I have to do things with.
My time I had to stand staying home and I
don't want my face how I want to work. Want to lend
money on me now on and things
like pay bills and I don't have a crush on
Mom I mean every
child. Yeah I mean
he doesn't know so I don't
know some of the
you know
the program you know I just stayed home and let the
school Pierce did it I did too and our light foam
there appears to you know
I was a liar. A lot of my friends in
hanging around in the school work in
a garage where the normal to what was constant
in a film then I continued at school these
days here. If
they thought it was a school in Brooklyn
so drastic college
but you know the school of that
island and then as
I now wonder why I've been there I've
been there one half a
sixteen S the first program that I
will back that I don't want to live that they have the
station that they have a station with a knife in
these women to the college so none of them have thought this
vocational program that was going to help me out of
college that's now call axis We
had me go to Long Island
City the Brooklyn College and there I was and then pick
a college program. A
lot of know how this was a different experience for me I
was all my own I was in a different world
environment how to cope on my own and then how
to be responsible and take care that they
are surrounding me to do and you know I'm literally helpful
people there when I was in the pre-college Cup program
I took some very hard classes they didn't know how
to
how to do that great mythology
and hardest thing for me to do. But I'm learning
that I'm learning a lot of different history and
set it on and that's how
it's like Martin Luther King in roles of products
my don't faze me because he was all
about civil rights and discrimination so I mean
for our rights in
leadership and.
It's those are
older talked about
your mom and me have
family here are encouraged to really finish strong
because I want to do something different and school
I want to do there is something that's been
they have those Tahsin non-so rather test sites
. I'm going to do
more schooling. I want to go black schools.
See if I can do the work. But
I'm not the only finish college I wanted to go
that I really need to finish up finish the
take up of. I did finish the college prep
program completion
from that and then on to a
an employment program. Now listen if you know accession
section where you know I was
learning how to do
job skills my child with a hand
and it was it in the right environment type environment for me
to them because I know a lot of job skills
like clerical I'll have a knot of the following
typing Anthony Colerain Alphabetical
Order order. I just wasn't ready
to do clerical work
. It was not another she was a secretary
to being a secretary and a lawyer finance.
Then I went to the job path and the job
the clerical chaining are not more glaring Courtrai
chop chop chop
at the end the Hatten a less than extreme
.
So it's something you have a lot of support from
various organisations. Yes other organisations
are here. Your experience with the
types of resources and time to
answer is a shift to the way
open sessions that I have to help me along the way. Well as
you see P Y A I
mean just as
that's pretty much.
As you mentioned you think
you know you
are changed over the years
.
None of those things change I want to be I want to
go out to do with ourselves
and me to do training. Now
jackass at the Brotherton cold factory I was
working in the basement. Put in
past some closed and pulls on hangers
. I've been there and I learnt how to
you know of the locals and put it neatly on hangers
and learn how to put pet how to put the tags on the poles
and you know sort the clothes at the close
lock the packs on the clothes that were
large put the taps on the clothes that was medium
and put the past on the clothes that was small and
it was a really good bands for me but the
then Dean was very
awful. There is a job where I can
sit more on the stand because
they get tired of it fast and
I just want to know that's Asli
fit.
Because this nation. Yes
I was acting
as well. And I
mean well and it does affect me
but it has over the years
since I was ten years since I had to
have back surgery on my back
I got placed on my back and
I can't I can't let heavy things
have boxes. This
was worse. Yes the skull the answers.
Right here in San felt
good and that
no one is sick I didn't play and the only
thing I don't play mostly more is chosen
songs and you know birthday song then
that's all I think I'm not gonna play I've been nothing but Yes
Twinkle twinkle little star.
But they saw a heavy price.
Yeah I'm getting that through slowly
not rationally.
Here I'm not home and I wanna
take more lessons so
much. Well you
know when
no one you know my mother was
a child she was going to
have a thought in a million years
in the vision or with a disability but not parents. I'm happy
they see me now from when intimate things that I need to
do with my life. On the south side of the kit
and speak of myself as well as others who isn't any
of my help and won't can't really speak for
themselves in my
shows one of the chain than why I asked and the nurse on
how to on how to cheat in the real and the visuals
and get the staff and are quick to
replace Matthias see what it is like to be and then that
same person shows all right for a while and I
rather wish I had been Ben with me in today.
I've got enough so to see you or because
I did my first speech at the Brooklyn branch
in two thousand and fourteen
I'm better on the person.
I did my first petition to get
an element of doubt at the kids and then stationed
in Crown Heights. That's a look at it on a simpler way and if patient
is not
game and knows a lot more
goes out while I'm doing my lane and
one I mean I have been
through a lot a dozen and though
this is one and I want to end the
interview to let us
know what I'm
doing in my life. No
it's
just acting as
though you're just being friendly and taking
a question now you actin people
know how things are happening
and write write
plays in. All
right players are apparently I mean they play
as in Why should the shows in the
closet Christ's salvation and the American street
map machine is about Barack Obama and
McCain how they met. You know
how to Peerless to me the
first time. Well well what do you say to
me Well well well well
said Kaine Horman. OK say to
someone else that
you know like her
old between and I don't mean in
the time and get the
outfit in the chorus in how
the sales would be enough
for them to love it. I'm doing it on the sunshine.
All in India or mom players to read
this at the in the Billie Holiday
of street. I don't
want to be a lead in to the station a
little bit to where my family and friends come
and see. I say what I have
what I will do in a landfill are willing one
place to do this is
history. Yes. No
I really want to build an acting school
and learn how to act because I think being that
active thing for me. I mean you have
some artists will are born actors will know how to
act. Boy when
you boil it you just know I am at but I'm just wondering
though to act in schools and to learn
how to be an actor and learn how to
do role play a sort of thing you
know.
Just so
you can use that is great experience
. Can you talk
a little bit or way you do in
your free time that
you're working towards here
. I looked at
the whole line but I had them ball and
one stop at bowling.
I let the gut.
OK a lot to chew on for a second she
won't pick pitcher then and then the
end of photography of
Durrant photography death for my favorite hobbies
and top three because my
uncle Johnny. So I want to
be I want to take the pictures that he has.
Here let me take chances you say where are you with
camera taking shelter here. Yeah. Shouts a moment
alike alike taken pictures with different things to people
.
So I take it back a little bit. Do to your timing
issues child care and anything to talk
to him
he took it and about the transition from wacky to me you
are well aware of the challenges for you
to buy us time to tie
it back and forth but what to do
what to do.
Those pertaining say it's
harder now is heart
ruff and his friends here
. For me it is now
my Walky Is it easy to make friends
. I fell on my friends
and walking and all that I got taught to
all Facebook but is not this not the same mercy
and I mean
anything. So they fall
away and I can bring them here
.
I hate it.
It's because you
know I mean since Les shot to me
shot too hard to make friends
in here and work you know
I was in all space and environment
meeting fans being my friends that want to be
around me and then talk about me no harm up that you
know spare room others name me being
down and now a woman
I like more or less
as a woman I mean I think I think
the chances for me.
Let me
quote me because I want to go
to Amazon and because I have one plane
which I hate I don't like and plantain Morris says
the September eleventh thing happen
as
it's true. Since
I was visiting my
Mom let's get on an airplane
. Then I asked my mom can we take the chain you know
to rise. She then get up
off the airplane and just have fun. But you
know I have my get in line. As long
as I'm not.
A well planned but
not anymore. Since September eleventh in the
Territory terrorists but the terrorists there's still a
question here about play I said and when I ask it of the
level of the sky and
then
you mother she
is amazing.
She's a psychic chick
social scientists I
think you see. Yeah she helps people
and shoots her right now. She
she was helping people.
Yes but not to mean that
Sue that's shown me that she can help
people and still be and still be
the person that she has become and her life. Because
I know now that I use
adult will hire a child and see her off as she has a bit
off this way. Then skin couch and share
can certainly complain and she talk to people
about what's going on in their lives. China I think
now was good was what the good things
go back to and how they could overcome what they
do in their life and she just sit down and talk to them and
they listen. But
listen to them and get them thinking that and
a lot that I like people to be
kind to help people in the area
. Here
you see
some
things only help people learn
a lesson we more right in
a no I just want this thing
in my life like I want to help more. I
want to die so community
and. One of their barracks
and been more helpful to people in need of help
that my grandmother has many years for many in
the US is that I
like really where
I am. So yeah and I think
how
people Laura like it tasted like T.
staff members and agencies
talk to will end up in the visuals with
disability and have to
develop a relationship. Well let's
not be so afraid to come along and ask both a
question.
If you were here for some
reason their eyes how to cheat or to talk to
people is just
just pete
. To us that nicely.
We won't buy a thing or we're all right you know
. But we will be
helping him out in any way that we can
and if you need support from the US who knows what you know
because the stress for us nothing that we have done in
our lives.
Why can't we support them and what they do and then.
Yes.
Are. They. Used. To
. Teenagers. That. We have. We
. Have.
Some. Good teenagers
. Because
. They
mean more hot. Then others. I mean. Then that
. They. Then went home and then they
. Had. That. All of us need help in some way.
But. To help to understand
. How cool.
She is. And how to
. Develop a friendship with us and not be
scared to come up to us. And
help us with the dance that we need help with.
And they think in your view this. Is a new
. Units. That you wish it were
.
Money.
On really in the you know the number I mean that women in
.
All
. Of
the luck like to hydro right when my right hand
.
It's. Not. About
Mess about it. This is
because it is ours. Yes.
I. Mean
. Me
.
She's a wonderful woman.
She has been there for me. Cian share that name volunteer.
She was workin for a street in Brooklyn New York.
She. Then me being in her
. Own writing a. Program that she had
.
To show me how to. Do self-discipline and.
She lets me know on the show that.
She she. She she
.
My mom is amazing because. I never got a chance to see
my mother. As she followed for of South
Africa. In two thousand and. Eight.
I got a chance to say I'm not going to the very first time.
She let me and so there have been a sane
. For me and she wasn't anything
to find its muscle and then. You know
a conversation and then she was
home. Now and I have fun. And
. I got a chance on the first time. This.
Amazing. And was that I would
never ever think. You. Might go
and say. I've got to
. Now I will. Not go. That
route. Never met before that falling out of them. Me
She has the same name as me and the same with me as
well in the shoe
. And she was born in Ethiopia Africa
. And edges are so nice and I. Am.
Other nation. And. Its fate
faithful. But I bet they haven't lost it
. Sloan communicate face
.
To face. It's
. Why. You
.
Are.
So karma
.
Arizona. When I had kids. She is
amazing. She went to school. She went to
school for cosmetology and
massage therapy. She gone back to school get an
education. Not to nephew. Amazing
. My.
Nephew Mari for autism.
For. Helping me. As an
individual with a disability and didn't have them and they're saying this was
until. Oh
. Say it will be easy it's not easy for us
just to. Have the vision. She
had won the race. But is definitely. Ha ha
ha ha. Ha Ha Ha to
maintain because a lot of
. US A. Lot of Love
.
I was up in the visions on that. There.
It's. You know. It's. You.
Know. It's
.
A. Suit
You as well.
As amazing. When he came. Here. To
visit me in Brooklyn. In the I thought you know how
did you draw in. The
very first time I was like.
Two children. He charges his share of the sonic
has a super hero who
did. It.
I didn't know you know how to draw a mommy in ourselves shop
because.
I didn't know I did not know that and I'm not sure how to chill.
Well my mother knows how to assistant manager
. And then the film are in the
. Jar and I was also in that scene
but.
It was awesome. Seen him do thank
.
You.
Yeah. Then they're talented
.
Listen again.
He sounds like you mean
.
And my other nephew. Oh that's a muggle
nephew he's eighteen and he is going to have a high
school. May nineteenth. Calling.
On. May twelfth
. Indian wife to say you know. That I was away from high school. It's
going to be a very. Big event and this is for me
.
First. Say my nephew graduate from high school.
If something goes WAY high school one thing him
. Because he was a baby of
Bailey then but. You
.
Know. Right. Now
you're able to go on your own. Yeah
you know I don't like it. No I mean everyone has their fears
. And. They're. Very very
. Weird.
So he told. Me. To lean on each
. Other.
It's a what do
. You prefer. Well. What
. Do you
mean to. Really. Work. Asked.
You. Years three years in writing which is a
very limited acting.
Goals are you.
Counting money. That have a cult wanting more.
Then
.
I think. One
of them. Got to college in the early
something. Like writing
. Creative writing and
.
Yet. They know all and.
Yet. Well
. After.
That more of the fun. And
focus. On getting cation
. And.
Getting. Creative writing mucho Knutzon.
Here.
You go. Yeah. This
. Work I'm. Glad to.
Have. It.
In that hope. From the planners and
. Making that time
happened.
That teaches you about the history. Of
. This enable. Us to
really really know how to write you know that are
saying this in that the right to Cairo and hello
to you because I don't know that. And
.
This. Is.
As people. First Language first thing.
This. Flu virus. That I have said with
quality in their tests and the minister with a disability
policy. That's it that's all I have. I'm not a person whether
this was a party and I'm glad that I have. I'm
glad that I was born with it because not only does not define
me.
Of who I
.
Am I want to sell. People for this thing.
I'm. Really. Do.
You.
Yeah. Being
more. Topics on
this. Bloody
history. I don't like to hear that.
Stance. And being more. Or so
. So. No more things and I
got a chance to learn more things. You know this
amazing.
Thing I want to take the class again. But.
I can. Take the closed
.
Door.
No. But.
They have isolation lack in us. That I could be
involved in. You know. The question was when I would
also. Like to see.
My classmates and classmates for work in
partners and others to make important for me and
. Get. To know them get
to speak to them to understand what they.
Are Really.
Well last. What's gone on and they land
. And they're not understanding but. An
. Opportunity in. The feminine
. Aspects. Of their
lives. It's
. Very interesting.
Where's. The chorus and how do we. Get
started. Oh no. Yeah.
Yeah.
I'm. A little sick or help me
do. A lot of things. Get involved. In writing
. And fishing. And
. Do. The attic
and let people know. The thing that's true
.
And go Oh yeah.
I think that that's a very you know. I'm.
Sure you're using as an advocate. Train
. Right insisting. That
. Usually. There
. Is no room. To ask for more.
Rights. And
. That.
NASA says. They can. Take. A look at it
. For themselves. And. Then takes
. A supportive person. To help
end the show for what they want. Before they
need someone. Saying. They want out of their
lives. Then as a standalone us who are not willing to
help. And the vision to know. And she
. The thing is that they want out of. Their Lives
. And at the end they need. To have
. In their lives. Of one was
. There I saw another cells. You know
are here a set and the vision is for the disability. Some
do some tell. Me I just wanna
. Know and I han't you know that. And the
visions with disabilities. Need. Help.
As much as I mean. As much as anything else
.
We end that.
They didn't nature. Out in the night
. And we want to
support us. In. The things
that we need to. Get out of our lives
.
This is. Why. I don't work in a
cell or a warrant from the Brooklyn are wrong on
the little council because.
I had a very first speech. On
.
Friday. Friday March seventh two thousand and fourteen
at the beach.
It's not just practice. That was how.
I thought in planning out in. Right now the chance to speak to the
different. Writers and how and where my
services are to me and how important
.
The services.
Are important to individuals with disabilities who will
see spouses from different agencies as well as
. A loved one in fact that I've got a chance to speak.
To as I say this because I've got I've got to let them
know I feel I'm
alive and best thing about what lessons
are important to me to have. In my life. That when
I was a little girl. When I was
.
You C.P.. The regal parts tourist center
. And. The man
. I was our father. Services between
. You C.P. have helped me. Physical.
Therapy.
Over time show and told. They have helped
me a lot in my life and I'm so grateful for you
C.P. for helping me out in there for me. Then
. They're older. And when I
was away from high school in Milwaukee Wisconsin. That's
why. I've been I've been a part of my
first six years. I mean. Yeah of
. Course I. Was. And
. They have a
say shame. Yeah but they have visitation wasn't
only for me and I'm going to college. And then from
college and the employment program. Then.
The program came back. To
why I.
And then if America. Via repetition.
Welcome to the why international confidence
nothing has called it in my shoes. Into that
Senate vote what that will make me want
to get. A woman to.
Teach. To defend a stagnant us on how to cheat
and issues with disability and showed them
aspects. Of what I had. Led to
and been through in my life. I mean it was
also. Then.
I thought of the and national school. And. Became. Never moved
from museum and I've been doing that for
. Eight years. I'm nine years. And I
love it and.
I don't do. Mall stories
. Alive.
Ecstasies News that. I was
on many a was. A
part of. It's just amazing
. Oh. I do rule. And. McCain
as. A person I've
. Never really talked
in really didn't do nothing. So
. Here I am
today. I'm happy.
I'm still. Well the thing is that I want to Dillon's and
.
I remember I was my first time. In two
thousand.
Two thousand. So then. When I went to. The state
to have advocacy.
Sponsored to go. And. Now of
course my uncle had by.
The. Mayflower Act will have gone
with me but this got me. To
Albany in
.
A lot of the law. And rule.
It's like. This
. And. Yes
. You
. Know.
You can you
. Really are
ready to
. Work. Hard for. Someone
.
How well or. Trying to. Maintain a
lie and. Maintain and.
Maintain maintain
.
Maintain. Life then
. I have.
A friends making friends. And
. The one thing a felony to do. I thought
my program why I
invent same.
And. Just focusing on a thing of I don't want
to. Do in my life.
This. Frantic. Big city
.
You know. Thank you so much for sharing your story. Is there anything else you want
. To. Tell. Us
. It's.
Not shit.
Thank you. I mean that is
. All that way and
.
Thank you adding
to the collection of, you know, wonderful stories
. This is my. Ideas
. With. It. And we
disconnected the this early experience with the
. New. Year. I. Believe it is
March twenty second twenty fifteen and we are at
. The library. Thanks again. Here it
. Is. Just.